the whole reason why we are interested
in string theory is that we believe the
world is governed at least in certain
energy scales by the general theory of
relativity we believe that on
sufficiently small scales quantum
mechanics shows its colors and we
believe there are Realms in which
general pivoting quantum mechanics need
to play together and so the value of
string theory in physics is that it
gives us a quantum theory of gravity
concern about string theory is that
string theory works like no other
science this Theory plays by
sociological and and economically
different rules because this community
secretly thinks that it is smarter than
the other communities and in general
this is in fact true I'm not arguing it
what I am claiming is that that level of
intelligence has been misspent
foreign